Speaking of embarrassment and shame, a new
poll confirms what should obviously be the
case.
And yet in America, when 60 million people
voted for Donald Trump, it would be wrong
to assume that what makes sense will be.
Most Americans are embarrassed, however, by
the Trump corona virus response, according
to a new SSR poll.
So not only are we the laughing stock of the
world and the pity of the world, we are also
embarrassed.
Which is good.
We should be the right emotion is to be embarrassed
by what we've done on this planet.
As far as coronavirus is concerned, so a few
notes from this poll, disapproval of Trump's
handling of the virus is up to 58 percent.
Great.
But how does 42 percent of the country think
Trump did a good job on the virus?
That's a problem.
Eight in 10 Americans are angry about the
response.
And 51 percent are very angry.
Well, people should be angry, but that's deceptive
because some people are angry because of how
bad the response has been.
While some people are angry that they have
to wear masks, so that one is a little bit
less clear.
But then the headline, seven in 10 Americans
are embarrassed by the response.
And we should be embarrassed because it's
been embarrassing.
And now there are also two important indicators
in this poll about when things should start
to return to normal.
Now, 57 percent of Americans say schools should
not open for in-person classes in the fall.
Some have already opened.
But that's not a huge majority anyway.
Only 57 percent say keep schools closed in
the fall for in-person do remote for sports.
Forty nine percent of Americans say there
should not be in person sports.
Forty five percent of Americans say there
should be in person sports.
These are really depressing numbers.
Even with this polarized country, you would
think you would hope that almost everyone
would realize, guys, this is embarrassing.
Obviously, we're not in a position to open
schools right now.
It's not about never open them.
It's about let's just do remote for one more
semester and then hopefully we'll have a vaccine
and better treatments and things can start
to normalize in early 2021.
No embarrassing schools shouldn't yet open.
But that's not what most people or what nearly
half of Americans believe.
Now, don't forget, when you look at these
numbers, we talked about this yesterday on
the show.
Somewhere between 40 and 50 percent of this
country doesn't even plan to get the vaccine,
which will make herd immunity impossible in
any kind of short to medium term.
So the real headlines here are reversed, right?
Instead of.
Wow, 70 percent of Americans embarrassed by
Trump's coronavirus response.
The red alert is whoa.
Thirty percent of Americans aren't embarrassed
by Trump's corona virus response.
That's where the focus should be.
That's about 100 million people.
If you include, you know, out of the full
population, which includes kids, but fine
with adults, it would be some smaller number
than that.
20 percent of Americans aren't angry about
Trump's coronavirus response.
What?
That's like 60 million people.
Oh, wait.
Trump got about 60 million votes in 2016.
Now, if we go back to embarrassment for a
second, yeah, we should be embarrassed about
Trump's response to coronavirus.
And I am.
But we should be just as embarrassed by the
reactions and the behavior of a huge portion
of the country's people.
I've said before, when Trump leaves, we still
have 60 million Trump ists to deal with.
We've seen protests against mass squaring.
We've seen protests against social distancing
guidelines.
We've seen people losing their minds in Costco's
and Wal-Mart's about liberty and freedom over
wearing a mask and trying to stop the spread
of a virus.
Conspiracy theories about Dr. Anthony Foushee
to the point where he needs security and his
daughters need security.
Bill Gates wants to microchip you.
It is embarrassing what Trump has done, but
it's doubly embarrassing when we look not
at Trump himself, but at his administration's
response at the people around him.
And at our fellow Americans.
At some point we're going to be past this
and we'll be able to do a postmortem.
And we will need to include in our analysis,
not just an analysis of what Trump did and
didn't do, not just an analysis of what the
Trump administration didn't didn't do.
But we're going to need to do an analysis
of the 60 million people who voted once for
this guy and are going to vote for him a second
time.
Hopefully, it won't be enough to give him
another four years.
And we have to contend with them for a very
long time.
And I've not gotten any good answers to this.
I've now talked about this for a couple of
weeks.
And the main point is if Trump wins, he's
going to do it with sixty five, 66, 67 million
voters.
If Trump loses, he's going to lose with 60
to 63 million voters, maybe even 64 million
voters.
Even if he loses, we have 60 something million
Trump ists in this country.
They're on school boards.
They are working in stores that you go to.
They are maybe your family, they're maybe
your relatives, your friends, whatever.
What do we do about that?
Because we as a country are not really going
to be able to advance until we do something
to weed out the ideology that got 60 million
plus people to vote for Trump.
Not once, but no doubt.
Twice or we have to figure out a way to make
progress around them.
Or despite them.
And I don't know what the answer is.
I'm always open to hearing ideas from you.
Sunday is the 15th anniversary of the David
Pakman show.
August twenty third.
I still remember that first show.
It was pretty bad.
But to commemorate the 15th anniversary on
Sunday, we'll be doing a one day huge membership
special.
The goal being to bring in more new members
this month than ever before.
If you'd like to be notified about this great
special, it's really, really good.
It's actually it is by far the biggest special
we've run this year, really ever.
I would say.
And from the standpoint of dollars.
OK.
So all you need to do to be notified on Sunday
is get on my newsletter, my mailing list.
You go to David Pakman dot com top right of
the page.
You will see a place to just type in your
e-mail.
That's all you have to do.
And then Sunday, you will be notified.
Let's go to a quick break.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
I want to hear what you make of the latest
week in America post DNC, pre RNC.
And we'll be back in just a couple
of minutes.